so abuse used to just be a man hitting a
woman right but what they do is they say
no no no there's more things that we
include in abuse and the things that
they include for abuse only count for
men forcing women to do thing forcing
women to do things or pressuring women
to do things they don't want to do but
never vice versa imagine if men could
press charges for coercing them into
marriage in a family how many men get
married because they just want to make
their woman happy is that coer coercion
so what they do is and they expand these
definitions so they add in um Financial
abuse emotional AB like what is
emotional abuse what about a woman
crying over nothing is that emotionally
abusing the guy because you know he's
sympathetic to you why why and that's
why I say if you are pushing that
emotional abuse is real you are just as
bad as the feminist